[Music]
i think that our theories and accounts
of the world
are
tools to help us intervene i don't think
they're description of some ultimate
reality and so in an overall way yes i
think we should be building metaphysical
stories about our overall uh situation
in fact i don't think we can avoid doing
that but i think we have to give up the
idea that any one of them might in fact
uncover the ultimate truth of how things
are thank you patricia do you have a
definition of metaphysics you are
working with
no i don't i mean i'm very old-fashioned
philosophers especially in what we may
call the tick tock era of metaphysics
have become really enamored of giving a
very deep
meaning to metaphysics
and quite honestly i find it sort of a
waste of time there are the
neuroscientists who are discovering
things about consciousness and there's
hillary said you're never really gonna
know what the nature of our purpose is
and they said yeah yeah but i know these
people are in pain and we're trying to
help them and so i'm fine with people
who want to do these great grand things
that aristotle would not have called
metaphysics but they do
uh go ahead be my guest um but i'm
really interested in making actual
progress
hillary you seem to want to say
something well
funny about that
[Applause]
i think
patricia also has a grand story it's the
modernist story that science is
understanding what's really going on
that we only have to apply observation
and reason and that we will gradually
uncover the truth about the universe and
i am alongside her look it's very
difficult to make predictions in science
i have no idea
whether science will ultimately uncover
the ultimate reality
what we do try to do is to make progress
in very specific ways in very specific
with very specific questions
always recognizing that there may be
aspects of the story that are completely
wrong we're now beginning to understand
what precisely changes in the brain
when we take ketamine
and how it produces those effects
and we can produce them electrically and
then get rid of them electrically and it
helps us i think understand something
that is
deeply problematic for many
psychiatric patients who have
really quite debilitating dissociative
feelings
so might we be able to harness this in
order to make a difference to people's
lives i think so does that mean we're
getting to the ultimate nature of
reality quite honestly that never
bothers me when i'm trying to go to
sleep i don't worry about that i'm
worrying about the data and how the data
fit together and how we can test it even
better
i'm not an idealist i don't think
there's just stuff going on in our heads
and there's no stuff out there engine so
instead i think we operate with what i
call closures but you could think of
them as models
and we use those models to intervene in
the world and i don't think there are
true ones so i'm i think
i understand what patricia is trying i
think to say but i wouldn't choose quite
that vocabulary i wouldn't say we are
working out how consciousness works
we're getting to the bottom of it i
wouldn't choose that vocabulary i would
say our model of how we interpret the
world our understanding of brain
processes is improving it's enabling us
to intervene better but just in the same
way as uh you know this pen could be
made better perhaps it could flow better
it could make it make it it could appear
uh more attractive
we wouldn't ever say oh we've got a true
pen
we might say we've got a better pen or a
worse pen that it's more useful at doing
this or use but it's not a true pen and
i think the same is true of our accounts
of consciousness or of reality or
whatever that they are ways that enable
us to do things and we can make them
better and better but that doesn't mean
to say they get any closer they are just
tools to make things happen
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas